hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions a B and C
have a party person a brings five cakes
person B brings three cakes person C
brings eight dollars a B and C believe
in sharing they divide the cakes so
everyone eats the same amount person C
then splits the eight dollars to a and B
fairly
how much should see pay 2a and 2b now
before I go on I want to mention a very
popular educational video on YouTube
begins by asking who doesn't like
birthday cake I get that many people
like cake and I use cake in my math
problems too but as someone who does not
eat birthday cake and does not regularly
eat cake I want to suggest maybe we can
encourage eating healthier foods in our
math problems so I originally heard this
story told
which chapatis a whole wheat unleavened
flatbread and I personally enjoy eating
tortillas in particular white corn
tortillas are inexpensive and easily
available to me so let's encourage these
healthier foods in our math problems
furthermore my videos will make you so
smart that even difficult problems will
become easy to you in videos like this
you'll see people requesting harder
problems and that's the best proof that
these videos are teaching math to people
around the world can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so person a brings five tortillas person
B brings three tortillas and person C
brings $8 since there are eight
tortillas and si has eight dollars it
seems like si should give one dollar per
tortilla meaning five dollars to a and
three dollars to B but in fact the fair
split is seven dollars to a and one
dollar to be why is that well to divide
into three people let's cut each
tortilla into three parts now we can
count the number of parts and we'll see
there are eight times three which equals
twenty-four pieces in total so each
person should get 24 over 3 which equals
8 of these pieces in order for the split
to happen a needs to give seven pieces
to C and B needs to give one piece to C
so now you can see that every single
person has the exact same amount of food
C is giving eight dollars for a total of
eight pieces which means each piece is
worth one dollar consequently C should
pay seven dollars to a for those seven
pieces and one dollar to be for that one
piece did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video these math videos
inspire and build confidence for people
around the world and they already have
over a hundred million views but the
math meanies never praise them and
spread negativity let's be extra
positive to cancel them out please help
by subscribing for free to get the
newest videos and by watching and
sharing all of the videos on mind your
decisions you can also email me a puzzle
or math topic at presh at mind your
decisions comm if you so choose you can
also check out my books which are linked
in the video description and you can
support me on patreon to earn exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support